And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
It's early in the morning and the Lord just really put it on my heart to be prayed for people and to just share how I pray for myself at different times of trouble and how I pray for our members at different times of trouble and at our family members at different times of trouble.
I just hope this will be an encouragement to you.
You know, our life gives us all sorts of troubles.
We can't get away from our troubles and whether it's a grave diagnosis or financial straight or whatever it is.
And I know that God gives us wisdom to seek out help, seek out providers, seek out doctors, seek out somebody that has knowledge that we don't to solve our situation.
And that's our offer to our first instinct is to do that to get rid of my problem.
That's what we want as humans. We want peace. We want safety. We want comfort.
And that's only human nature. But my prayer is that through my troubles that I can allow at least one purpose in my troubles is to drive me to him.
Because if I claim to be a believer in Jesus Christ, he should be the first one that I seek.
But often he isn't, you know, I'll run to a doctor or run to, you know, for help or run to solve my problems, study to try to figure it out.
That's how I made.
And that's, I think that's an error. I need to seek him first and know that, you know, he's allowed this in my life for some reason.
At least one of the reasons and maybe I think the most important reason is for me to develop a closer relationship with him than I had yesterday.
That's really what my purpose of life is, is to grow in that relationship.
That's what being molded and shaped to the image of his son is, is to allow our life's experiences.
And sometimes it takes the difficult life experiences to drive us to him in a deeper way.
That's what maturity is. I'm going to still fall in my flesh. I'm going to still sit every day. I'm going to still think wrong thoughts.
I'm going to still rely on me, rely on others to solve my problems. I'm going to still seek to get out of my problems.
But please, my prayer for myself is, Lord, allow my difficulties in life to drive me closer to you so that I can crawl up on your lap and just hear you say the words that you need to say to me and speak to me and you need to teach me.
This is my prayer for my members. That's my prayer for you. If you don't seek care. And with us, I want you to seek him first, really, honestly, to seek him first in everything, to allow your struggles to drive you closer to him in a deeper relationship.
My prayer is for you. I said, my prayer is for me. And I fail at that every day. And I pray that he can teach me more today to do that better and maybe faster than I did yesterday.
Thank you. I love you all. Bye bye.